[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
emotional testimony in minnesota from
those closest to dante wright it was the
worst day of my life your boyfriend was
shot right in front of you right yes the
jury head to deliberation after closing
arguments in the trial of accused
murderer lindley renick
somebody used a gun out there
i submit to you it was lonely
but even if it was michael the evidence
proves she's guilty beyond a reasonable
doubt
florida
the continuation of pre-trial motions
the parkland shooters defense team
motions to remove the death penalty
ahead of next month's sentencing and
later
scott peterson is innocent convicted
wife killer scott peterson is
re-sentenced as his family maintains his
innocence law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
everyone to law and crime daily i'm
brian buckmeyer along with terry austin
emotional testimony begins day two of
minnesota vs kim potter
where the prosecution's first witness of
the day is dante wright's girlfriend the
woman who sat beside him as he was shot
and killed
ex-minnesota officer kim potter faced
his first and second degree manslaughter
charges in the death of 20 year old
wright when officers pulled right over
during a traffic stop they discovered a
warren was out for his arrest after that
there was a struggle between wright and
the officers potter a 26-year veteran of
the force shot right in the chest he
died as a result of the injuries potter
maintained she accidentally grabbed her
gun body camera and squad car footage of
the incident were shown during opening
statements
yes
as its first witness the prosecution
called katie bryant the mother of dante
wright she described what she saw after
she arrived at the scene
i went under the yellow tape because
they've
seen i've seen them
a car crashed and i noticed it was my
son's car
and then in the front of his car
that's where he was laid
did you see your son's body on the
ground i did
so what did you do when you got to that
area
i was
so distraught i didn't know
what was happening
i just got off the phone and they said
he shot him but i seen a car crash i was
asking questions i didn't want to
believe that that was my son laying
there on the ground but i could tell it
was him because of his tennis shoes
the prosecution then showed jurors never
before seen body cam footage of brian's
first moments at the scene
he was
i was here i watched
[Music]
where's the girl that was in the car
with him
you guys made her hang up facebook live
so you can kill my son that's pretty
prophetic and then what's your son's
name
dante right it was not a high speed
chase you guys shot him in a pull over
traffic
yeah you did he was laying in his
subsequent dad his girlfriend facebooked
me how did his car get smashed
at the start of day two the prosecution
called elena albrecht peyton de wright's
girlfriend and the woman in the
passenger seat at the time of the
shooting she told jurors what happened
just moments after the shooting
i just grabbed whatever it was
and
put it on his chest like like you know
you've seen
these tv shows i didn't know what to do
so i just
i just put my hands over his testicles i
just tried to hold it and i was
just tried to scream his name
and he had to just try to have him talk
to me and just kept saying dante like
dante like just say something please
like just talk to me
did you just
like i know he wanted to
[Music]
because i would play that image in my
head daily
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney taylor cost and terry austin
taylor bodyborne camera has shown how
potter reacted saying she killed a boy
and is going to jail what do you think
she was worried about after the shooting
and how that play out in this case
thanks for having me guys always a
pleasure you know this is remarkable
body camera has changed the way that
trials are you know move forward the
jurors get to see things that in the
past they've only heard about and now
they get to see it with their own two
eyes and what we have here is
essentially either a real-time reaction
or pretty quick thinking on her feet um
it seems genuine it seems a genuine
reaction and what she's realizing in
that in those milliseconds right then
and there is that she's in big trouble
and guess what she is and you know this
highlights this video right here
highlights why police training in this
country needs to be rethought people
shouldn't be on the street with deadly
weapons until they are overly overly
trained to the point where a mistake
like this could never happen yes and
terry dante wright's mother and
girlfriend have now given us a glimpse
of what happened that day do you what do
you think the jury took away from their
testimony
brian i've seen a lot of family members
testify but never have i seen two
witnesses who were so emotional and so
convincing katie bryant the mother was
talking about the confusion at the scene
and her tears were real the fact that
she could not get to her son as a mother
i can completely relate to that and
elena payton described what she saw she
sat there in the front seat of that car
and saw her boyfriend getting shot and
killed it had to be traumatic it had to
be emotional great witnesses great
strategy on the part of the prosecution
yes absolutely on the next episode of
law and crime daily we sit down with
wright family attorney jeffrey storms
for his take on the first week of trial
switching to federal court in new york
where the gillane maxwell sex crimes
trial saw a shortened day on thursday
not long after the first witness was
called the judge was told one of the
attorneys is in the case was ill she
said there was no reason to believe it
was covet 19 related court broke for the
day and is set to reconvene friday
morning before court broke for the day a
paralegal at fedex took the stand to
authenticate invoices associated with
former financer jeffrey epstein's
account maxwell's accuser and farmer was
expected to testify before a court let
out early she is the last alleged victim
the prosecution will call maxwell faces
federal sex trafficking charges stemming
from her relationship with epstein the
two allegedly groomed teenage girls for
sexual abuse epstein maxwell's longtime
companion was found dead by suicide
after he was charged with similar crimes
still ahead on law and crime daily the
parkland school shooter asked that the
death penalty be taken off the table in
his sentencing
but first a verdict is returned in the
trial of accused husband killer lindley
renick what a missouri jury decided
after this
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
verdict is in a missouri jury who finds
31 year old lindley renick guilty on all
counts in the murder of her husband
benjamin renick
renick faces up to 30 years behind bars
for a second-degree murder conviction
renick was initially charged with
first-degree murder on thursday a judge
ordered bond be revoked and renick
remain in custody until the penalty
phase prosecutors say she owned a spa
that was losing money and that she was
the sole beneficiary of her husband's 1
million life insurance policy they say
rennick hatched a plan with her
ex-boyfriend michael humphrey and
co-worker ashley shaw to kill 29 year
old benjamin renick back in 2017.
humphrey was convicted of the same
charges back in october in closing
arguments on wednesday the prosecution
told jurors that lindley renick is the
only one who had any reason to kill her
husband
four people were involved in this
conspiracy
of those four people
only one person
had a motive to kill ben
only one person of those four people had
a connection
to all four people
of those four people
only one person
in covering up this
crime listened to the facebook chatter
and social media chatter and decided to
help cover up this crime by casting
attention in the scent of law
enforcement away
on the victim's brother
only one person continues to lie
of those four people that one person
is the defendant lindley reddick
in closing the defense argue benjamin
renek's murder was not being planned but
that ashley shah wanted to help lindley
get out of her marriage they claim
michael humphrey lindley's alleged
cohort had a motive to kill benjamin
renick
i submit to you the evidence shows these
women
ashley and lenny were planning a divorce
they pick up michael humphrey
michael humphrey is a meth addict
he uses methamphetamine
regularly
he doesn't like ben
this is his ex-girlfriend he asks a
neighbor how do you get somebody to stop
abusing their wife
why would he ask that
if like what ashley shaw said he already
agreed to kill ben after a day
if you've already agreed to kill
somebody within a couple of hours why
are you going to be asking your neighbor
how to get that person to stop beating
their wife
the answer is is because michael
humphrey and his meth adult
brain scoured down to sub idiot quality
is thinking to himself i'm gonna take a
gun and i hope he does do something
because then i can shoot him
and maybe i can get back with miami
back to discuss the verdict in lindley
renning's trial is criminal defense
attorney taylor cost and terry austin
terry a 12-hour verdict did you think
the jury would be grappling with any
fact or did you expect a verdict this
soon
actually i thought the verdict would
come in in two hours the evidence was
overwhelming they had the two main
individuals who were involved in this
conspiracy they had ashley shaw who was
the co-worker and she helped plan the
whole thing and while her credibility in
my opinion was a little questionable
because she had all the charges dropped
she was very credible on the stand and
forget it michael humphrey the
ex-boyfriend he had nothing to lose he
testified on the stand but he still was
going to be in jail for the rest of his
life nothing to lose very credible they
were all involved and i'm surprised it
took as long as it did but finally the
verdict came back guilty on all counts
all right so maybe uh 10 hours too long
but taylor let's ask this question
guilty verdicts can come about in one of
two ways either the prosecution wins or
the defense loses which do you think
renik's case was and why
so you know building a little bit off of
what terry had said you know sometimes
you know i would submit maybe brian
there's a third option and the third
option is the evidence is so strong in
the case that it actually doesn't matter
you know it doesn't matter how strong
the prosecution is or how weak the
defense is sometimes the evidence really
just speaks for itself now in this case
the evidence was overwhelming and i do
think that the defense arguments were
pretty weak you know uh suggesting that
the ex-boyfriend had a motive to kill
this individual was weak it fell flat
the delivery fell flat and i wasn't
buying any of it um this is a case where
i think heading into it
all observers from the outside looking
in legal observers thought this was
going to be a quick conviction it was a
quick conviction the system worked
exactly how it was supposed to work in
this case and it's a good day for
justice all right we'll see how justice
continues as sentencing is scheduled up
next for uh lindley reddick after being
found guilty of all charges
on to news out of florida where a jury
recommends a death sentence for
convicted killer markeith loyd last
month the same jury found lloyd guilty
of first-degree murder in the death of
orlando police officer deborah clayton
the 46-year-old shot and killed clayton
while she was trying to arrest him for
the murder of his pregnant ex-girlfriend
a month earlier lloyd avoided the death
penalty in that case but jurors
recommended one in this case ultimately
be the judge's decision where the lloyd
lives or dies
coming up on law and crime daily 20
years after the murder of his wife and
unborn son scott peterson is resentenced
to life in prison plus parkland school
shooter nicholas cruz asked a florida
judge to remove the possibility of the
death penalty hear her ruling ahead
[Music]
welcome back to lawn crime daily just
months after nicolas cruz pleads guilty
to the parkland school shooting massacre
his defense team asked that the death
penalty be taken off the table
in february 2018 crews opened fire at
margie stoneman douglas high school in
parkland florida 17 people were killed
and 17 more were injured in october
crews pled guilty to all charges
apologized to the court for the shooting
and blamed drugs for the cause
a jury will hear details of the case in
january and decide whether he should
receive the death penalty ahead of that
cruz's defense team asked the judge to
remove the possibility of a death
penalty sentence
the decision to seek death or wave death
or in fact any decisions regarding flea
offers for defendants charged with
homicide offenses simply had to be
approved by the state attorney himself
additionally there is no uniform or
structured procedure
used by state attorney offices in other
florida circuits each office has its own
method for making the determination as
to whether
it seeks the death penalty
the prosecution countered this motion
saying capital punishment fits the
severity of the crime
that decision to seek the death penalty
has been ratified by harold pryor who is
mr sassa's successor in this case there
are 17 victims of homicide committed by
this defendant over here this is a case
that calls out for the death penalty and
the death penalty is appropriate and it
is not being sought at the whim of one
man and the defendant's motion should be
denied
in the end judge elizabeth schreyer
ruled that the death penalty will be a
possible sentence for cruz she also
knocked down a defense request that
victim impact statements not be shown
publicly
let's bring in criminal defense attorney
taylor cost and co-host terry austin to
discuss cruz and the death penalty terry
it's a last but maybe not last-ditch
effort to take the death penalty off the
table what'd you think of the defense's
argument to remove the death penalty
there's no question the defense's
arguments were extremely weak look we
have a defendant who has pled guilty to
17 counts of murder and 17 counts of
attempted murder no question this is a
death penalty case the defense tried to
claim that the death penalty was
arbitrarily applied by the state no
matter what you think about past cases
this was not arbitrarily applied the
defense also tried to say that the
targeted school did not disrupt a public
function that was one of the aggravating
factors well it did disrupt a
governmental function so the judge
didn't buy any defense arguments and i
think that was absolutely the right
decision now taylor i think i can guess
what your answer may be but let me try
it anyways was the prosecution making
the right arguments here to keep the
death penalty off the table or was it
something else
yeah listen you know the death penalty
and the application of the death penalty
is a fairly simple but two-step process
the first step is does the case meet the
statutory requirements for the death
penalty very easy right and the second
step is very simple it's called
prosecutorial discretion okay each case
has to be
looked at
you have to assess each and every
mitigating and aggravating factor you
have to look each case from each other
and the district attorney an elected
official ultimately gets to make the
decision what penalty they will seek
it's not up to them to impose the
penalty it's just up to them to make a
decision whether or not they're going to
seek it and it is important that
prosecutors use this discretion because
there shouldn't be a blanket policy it
should be each individual case assessed
for strength weaknesses aggravating and
mitigating factors i would agree if
there's any case where the death penalty
may fit i can see why the argument would
be for this one of all other cases still
ahead on law and crime daily we head to
the west coast where convicted murderer
scott peterson is re-sentenced when we
come back hear from both sides about
peterson's potential retrial
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
convicted wife killer scott peterson is
resentenced to life in prison without
parole for the murder of his wife lacey
and unborn son on christmas eve 2002.
peterson wore a red jail jumpsuit during
the hearing wednesday tv cameras were
not allowed but still photos capture the
hearing lacey peterson's mother sharon
rocha and siblings spoke sharon rocha
said quote no matter what happens you
will always be their murderer and
outline the circumstantial evidence in
the case peterson could get at a new
trial if the judge finds a juror
intentionally lied to get on the jury
the 49-year-old was expected to speak at
the hearing but judge and christian
masolo didn't allow it because the life
sentence was mandatory peterson's
attorney and sister-in-law spoke after
the hearing ending
i think he just also wanted to reach out
and tell the rocha family that he
understands
their feelings and he understands why
they believe
that he is
guilty but he wanted to make it clear
that there is no way he could have
possibly harmed lacey and connor this is
a capital murder trial he is in prison
for murdering his wife and unborn son
there is no forensic evidence there is
no timeline to this crime scott peterson
is innocent
a hearing on the jury misconduct claim
will be held next february
taylor in a case with so many twists and
turns of technical arguments
what do you think of the judge stopping
peterson from speaking and could that
create some sort of a pellet issue
i have to be honest i don't understand
it um you know regardless of the fact
that the sentence was mandatory you know
we we are certainly as a country used to
defendants being able to speak at their
own sentence even if it's to just so
show some remorse i understand this case
is riddled with a ton of history but i
just don't see the upside in refusing to
let him speak i think it's a potential
error yeah now terry peterson is still
waiting for a new trial what's next for
him uh after the sentencing
you know peterson is going to have to
wait and see it was his team that moved
for this new trial they're claiming that
there was prejudicial misconduct as far
as juror number seven was concerned
they're saying that rochelle niece did
not disclose that she was a victim of
domestic violence she didn't disclose
that she had a restraining order against
her boyfriend's ex-girlfriend and so
there's also this new evidence that they
are claiming that lacey peterson was
killed when she stumbled upon you know
the burglary so i think in the meantime
until this hearing in late february his
attorneys are going to be trying to put
together evidence for this hearing and
trying to make sure that they have
enough to convince the judge that he
should get a new trial frankly i don't
think it's going to work and i think the
public out war will be huge because
there's no question based on the
evidence at the trial that he committed
this crime so we'll see what happens all
right sounds like the end of the chapter
but not the end of the story for scott
peterson thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you